I am Lena Headey and I play Cersei
Lannister when we meet Cersei we get to
know her relationship with both her
brothers one of them is her lover the
other one is someone she respects very
much but hates strangely I think
relationship with Jaime is less
complicated than a relationship with
Tyrion because she does have enormous
respect for him begrudging respect and
also hates him blames him for the loss
of her mother there's the scene of Jaime
and Cersei are playing hot sausage and
bran climbs the tower and he sees them
and Jaime pushes the small child who is
a stalk out of the window thinking he'll
push him to his death the things I do
for love
and then it all goes a little bit
tick-tock daenerys targaryen that's
chosen Tyrion to be harmed our little
brother the one you love so much the one
who set free the one who murdered our
Father and our firstborn son now he
stands beside iron amusing give some
counsel the father Tyrians now with
Danny drives her insane she can't bear
that he's alive we need allies stronger
better allies we can't win this war
alone she's going to use your own
because he has a strong Navy
but it's news to Jaime some other things
she hasn't discussed with him so he's
like who is this woman I just saw that a
Fanta fighter
they'll beat any army I've ever seen
killing our men was the wolf then it was
sport
but dragon burnt a thousand wagons
Qyburn scorpion five balls bigger than
you they couldn't stop it and she has to
be if this isn't a walk we can win
Cersei is furious that he wouldn't
believe in her it's like another sort of
broken wrong in their ladder their
relationship I've come to believe that
an accommodation with the Dragon Queen
could be in our immediate interest at
this point she's pregnant with Jaime's
child she's kind of back in love and
want this to work and then at the end
she says would never betray me again as
much as she loves Jaime there's now an
element of distrust which there hasn't
been she does come to see that a meeting
is the way forward and also it gives her
the opportunity to try and [ __ ] everyone
so she's quite happy about that rules
thing waiting for Danny to arrive and
these dragons stop circling in
everyone's hands off and is he
circe just doesn't move from here and
this is part of a power play you know
she's like I'll remain unimpressed and
then Danny arrives and she's beautiful
and she's late and those two things
drives us he insane
then she meets the white and is
terrified but even then thinks so beyond
dead you know and has a you know plan in
her pocket with your own so she chooses
to lie send everybody north hope hoping
they'll be murdered and she'll take
what's left in the fighting in the north
is over someone wins you understand that
don't you
if the dead win they must south and kill
us all if the living win and we've
betrayed them they march south and kill
us all one of the saddest moments of
Cersei and Jaime is his moral sensor
becomes really strong and I think he's
in from the influence of Brienne on him
he's more powerful in Cersei at this
moment and he thinks she's become a
monster I pledged to write north
I think you honor that pledge she pushes
him away and she doesn't think he'll
never leave her really and he does he
leaves
are you going to order him to kill me
I'm the only one you have left my
children are gone her father is gone
it's just me and you now there's one
more yet to come he walks out and again
she's unable to sort of say please don't
leave me I love it she can't say those
words to him
and so she loses him she loses the one
person that has always stood by her side
no matter how monstrous she's behaved
and he's gone he everybody is Charlie so
we got a new Circe Game of Thrones
season 8 promoter breakdown I love some
of the stuff she says in this I tried to
cut it down to the really important
stuff particularly the stuff that
informs where she's at at the beginning
of season 8 because there are a couple
really important things for her
characters namely her family her
relationship with Tyrion and Jaime even
though it's completely broken at this
point because Jamie's finally left her
but also the ticking time bomb that is
her baby which is probably one of the
greatest threats in season 8 next - like
the actual threat of the night king like
there are metaphorical threats and then
there are real threats the night king is
a real threat the baby is more of a
metaphorical threat because of what will
happen when things go badly with the
baby so we got to break it down there's
a new round of that Song of Ice and Fire
book giveaway going on - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so first things
first at the beginning of the video she
talks about her relationship with Tyrion
I love that she says that it's more
complicated than her relationship with
Jaime her relationship with Jaime just
sounds complicated like if you tried to
explain to someone well they're brother
and sister but they've been hiding it
their whole lives they're actually in
love with each other the important thing
about her relationship with Tyrion is is
that she still feels like he's family
she just resents him or has resented him
her whole life mostly because of the
loss of her mother and that becomes a
recurring theme between the two of them
it's why she gets so pissed off with him
during season two because he sends away
Marcela the other woman in her life that
she blames Tyrion for the loss of
although she also later blames Jaime for
not being able to protect Myrcella but
even though his Lena Headey wonderfully
talks about it like you just have to
love Lena Headey as a person the way she
talks about Cersei leash so nonchalant
about some of the craziest moments in
her character's history she talks about
how sir she felt like the only choice
left for her at the beginning of season
7 or the end of season 6 was to take the
Iron Throne because that was the only
thing left in her life until this new
baby came along because she saw that as
an opportunity to completely fix
everything like oh I can make this
fantasy of a little family unit that
I've been wanting my whole life a real
thing again Jamie lied to me I don't
trust him doesn't matter this new baby
will fix all of our problems and I love
her interpretation of Circe's actions at
the end of season 7 beginning of season
8 where she says she's using this baby
as an excuse to completely screw
everyone over because of what she thinks
that it means for her future we can be a
family again but then you have the other
side of this Jamie who's completely
found as moral Center thank you very
much Brienne who's finally making good
decisions calls her on her [ __ ] and
then tries to leave and she just can't
handle like her brain starts to melt
slowly so Perlina HEDIS explanation the
way she interprets this moment I don't
think that Cersei would have ever
actually ordered the mountain to kill
Jaime is if she's so surprised because
she never thought that he would have
left her so if you're not a big book
reader during feast for crows which they
kind of largely did during season four
beetle beginning of season five with the
Fate militant plot she slowly starts to
lose her mind and even though that's
been happening on the TV show it's been
a little more subtle on-screen than it
is in the books like she really does
start to go genuinely crazy so I think
what the TV show has done is they just
stretched that out so that she'll
finally lose her mind when the ticking
time-bomb that is the baby either
becomes stillborn or she loses it or
something terrible happens and Qyburn
has to explain to her that she's not
going to have this wonderful bundle of
joy that she's always gonna fix all of
her problems and that's it like the last
lingering threat of her sanity goes away
and she goes full-on mad queen
threatening everyone know even though
right now she's completely screwed
everyone over there's still a few people
that are loyal to her in the kingdom a
few houses she's still trying to
actually be queen she's got the alliance
with Iran she's got the golden company
on the way she's still somewhat trying
to prepare for what might come south
whether it be Jon Snow and Daenerys if
they win or the night King in the White
Walkers if they wind up winning but in
the way the game of Thrones
the TV show in A Song of Ice and Fire
and George RR Martin's books like to
repeat really big events you white up
with a situation similar to the end of
Robert's rebellion with the Mad King
saying burn them all and threatening
everyone even the people that he's
supposed to be protecting inside the
walls of King's Landing so as of right
now circe's pow'r move is still using a
lot of wildfire even though I think most
of it was burnt up when she blew up the
great set the show could always just
magic some up like Oh surprise we found
a bunch left over the real threat when
they come down to King's Landing like
there's a big battle happening up at
Winterfell so I think we do all believe
the Jon Snow Daenerys Tyrion Jaime they
will all make it back to King's Landing
at some point and there will be some
final confrontation with Cersei in the
real end of Game of Thrones that the
real big final conflict will be more
about what happens between those main
characters just like the way the season
1 like we started with White Walkers
this season is all about ending that
threat but the weird thing about the
show is that they've been positioning
Cersei as more and more of a main
villain than the night king itself or at
least as dangerous as the night king the
night king is just like a very visible
identifiable threat like all he cares
about is killing life but if Cersei goes
full Mad Queen after she potentially
loses her unborn child the last thing
that she cares about the last thing
that's making her saying there's the
threat that she'll do the exact same
thing just kill everyone because I don't
care about anything anymore everything
that I had hoped for is gone there's
nothing left to live for
who cares about anybody so big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
when do you think she loses that baby
during season a like which if they're
gonna be six episodes and do you
actually think that she's going to speak
the words burn them all that might be a
little too much maybe a little too
on-the-nose
even though I do expect history to
repeat itself just a little bit I really
hope that Naomi Watts who's like the
main female character that they just
named for the prequel series is going to
be as entertaining to watch as Lena
Headey has been to watch her play Cersei
we're heading into the holidays but
there are a bunch more promos that I
haven't done videos for yet so I'll do
those in the next week or so leave all
your requests in the comments below -
congratulations Evette walker you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for the Aria
start see
eight promo and click here for the brand
stark and the Jon Snow season 8 promos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you